The new Galaxy S10 is here and it’s packing
some pretty impressive battery life, but what
if there was a way to significantly increase
the amount of battery life you can get out
of it?
Well, from the results I found in this test,
there is, and it’s by using Android 9 Pie’s
new Night Mode, which you can easily toggle
from the notification panel.
Many of you know that the S10 uses an OLED
display, just like many other phones on the
market, but what you might not know is that
displaying black or dark pixels uses much
less battery power compared to white ones.
This test by senk9 shows just how much more
power the color white takes on OLED displays
compared to black, and with red and green
taking significantly less power than blue.
Now if you’ve got a phone with an LCD display,
like the iPhone XR, this won’t work because
unlike OLED, it lights up the whole display
panel.
With OLED, each pixel is individually backlit,
so if it’s displaying true black, it’s
completely turned off and isn’t using any
power.
So to test this out, we displayed the Reddit
homepage, which is almost completely white,
and measured the battery drain after 2 hours,
and then we did the same with Samsung’s
Night Mode enabled.
Before we began, we closed background apps,
set the power mode to optimized, turned off
the blue light filter, turned off adaptive
brightness, and set the brightness to the
max to show how big of a difference Night
Mode can make if you love maxing out your
brightness.
I used Samsung’s browser for this since
Chrome isn’t currently affected by Night
Mode, but Android Q is bringing a dark mode
to Chrome soon, so that’s pretty exciting.
Now let’s get into our battery test.
After spending 2 hours on the Reddit homepage
with Night Mode turned on, the battery went
from 100% to 92%, which is actually really
impressive considering the phone was at maximum
brightness.
We then charged it back up to 100%, turned
off Night Mode and ran the test again.
This time, the battery went from 100% to a
much lower 80%.
That’s a pretty decent difference for simply
turning on Night Mode, and that’s with the
Power Mode set to Optimized.
Now imagine if we used High-Performance mode,
which makes the display even brighter!
Also, if we would have extended this test
until the battery drained, just enabling Night
Mode would make the battery last an extra
15 hours compared to having it disabled.
So anyone who does a lot of browsing on bright
or white pages should definitely take advantage
of Night Mode to save some extra battery life.
But wait, there are more ways to save battery
life.
Simply using a black or dark wallpaper compared
to the stock wallpaper will help save battery
life as well.
Senk9 also tested brightness versus battery
consumption, and if you look at this graph,
you’ll see that battery drain shot through
the roof when above 80% brightness, so make
sure you don’t go above that if you care
about battery life.
Even better, just use adaptive brightness
and it’ll adjust it to match your environment.
This way, you’re not wasting battery power
when you’re indoors.
Another important thing to mention is that
you should set your screen timeout duration
to as short as is convenient for you.
If you set it to 10 minutes and constantly
forget to turn off your screen, your battery
will drain much quicker.
Finally, if you’re running low on battery
and need to stretch it out a few more hours,
Samsung’s built-in battery saving mode works
incredibly well.
If this video helped you out, make sure to
like and subscribe so you don’t miss out
on more videos like this one.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!